yes what's up my name's samuel leeds and
right now i am in the bahamas and it's
one of the things that shocked me is the
wealthy people in the bahamas the
wealthy people in mexico the wealthy
people in miami florida the wealthy
people in the uk they're all buying
properties and they're doing things in
the exact same way and this is something
that the poor and the middle class just
don't understand and are not doing so in
this video i wanted to share with you
how the rich are getting richer and how
you can join them too so this is
generally speaking what wealthy people
do and this is this is just
so so crazy because when i started out
in business i didn't even know you could
buy properties this way i didn't know
the strategies so this is how well
people buy properties what they do is
they buy them in cash
they might be oh but i haven't got the
cash exactly that's the point that's why
this is what the wealthy people do and
they buy properties in cash because they
know that most people like me when i got
started and probably you watching this
video maybe most people
can't buy properties in cash so they buy
properties in cash
because they buy in cash they buy it
really cheap
i'm in the bahamas right now i just i
just secured a property deal in miami
yesterday in miami florida and guess
what all the real realtors and the
agents were saying to me they were
saying look man the market's booming if
you want to get a good deal if you want
to get an off-market deal then you're
going to have to buy cash you have to
buy cash um oh this property's on for
half a million dollars but if you want
to get it for 400 000 no problem but you
have to buy it cash now
most people can't afford to compete with
rich people buying cash so
that's how they buy properties cash now
they don't just buy cash and then buy
the next one cash and then buy the next
one cash and do that with all their
deals because even rich people have got
a limited amount of funds what they do
is they buy cash
and then once they've bought it
they then get a mortgage on the property
this is such a smart way to buy property
deals let me explain why because you're
gonna tie your cash up yes for maybe
like six months
but you've bought the property
maybe twenty percent
thirty percent below market value
so
then when you refinance it and get a
mortgage on the property you're going to
refinance it and you're going to then
end up leaving a deposit in just like
most people would do if they bought a
property the normal way but the smart
thing is because you bought it below
market value when you then refinance it
you're put you're taking you're saying
you're in 75
of the
current actual value not the purchase
the lender is going to lend you 75
of the value not the purchase so what
you're going to do is you're going to
i'll give you an example you're gonna
buy a house for half a million dollars
i'm saying dollars because i've just
been in miami um you're gonna buy a
house for half a million dollars but the
value of the house is 650.
so you buy cash
you're wealthy right this is how the
rich get richer because they got the
cash in the first place so you put the
cash down you buy it for half a million
dollars but then six months later you
get a lender to come out value it they
value it at 650 they then give you 75
percent of 650 which is basically your
half a million pounds back so you take
your half a million pounds back and then
you go again you do it again and again
and that's how the rich get richer they
just keep continually recycling their
money they're saving money over and over
buying more and more properties and then
when they refinance of course they're
not going to pay tax on that refinance
and what if the smart ones the smart
property investors are buying problem
properties and fixing them maybe they're
buying properties with flying leasehold
issues or maybe it's a bit run down it's
a bit dated so they lift they refurb it
and no one can compete because no one
can cough up half a million pounds cash
even if it's just for six months now
what how's this relevant to maybe you
how was it how's this relevant to me
when i got started why tell you how it's
relevant
because you
don't necessarily need
your own cash
to buy these deals i'm thinking of doing
something this year
which is going to be a bit crazy and
this is going to be my way of giving
back and helping
pull as many people onto the rich side
as possible
um and i'm thinking of doing something
as a little bit of a way of giving back
but also as a business opportunity for
myself and for other people and what i'm
thinking of doing let me know in the
comments if you want to get in on this
challenge if you if you're interested in
maybe working together on this i am
looking to lend my money
okay because i'm rich now became wealthy
through property i'm looking to lend my
money
out on other people's maybe your deals
so you'll buy the house cash but you'll
use my cash
and then
six months later when we refinance it
we're gonna refinance it i'm gonna get
my cash back
and then we'll keep the property
together
how cool is that man so i'm in a good
mood right now today's my birthday i
just turned 31 years old today so i'm in
a really good mood and i'm thinking of
opening up some opportunities for people
and it doesn't have to be a half a
million pounds house or half a million
dollar house you know it could be maybe
if you've got other deals maybe if
you've got rent to rent opportunities or
you've got lease options or you've got
little flips little hmos i'm potentially
looking to open up to some small
investors that are finding deals that
are hungry that are trained but just
haven't got the finance to put down on
their deals so if you are interested in
maybe teaming up and collaborating on
that then let me know in the comments
let me know in the comments um and let
me know yes also hit the like button
share the video around
share your friends because honestly i'll
tell you something
the rich people
are going to continue getting richer and
richer and richer using this strategy
and the poor people
meanwhile the average person is just
saving up for a deposit on a house
and then they buy the house and then
because they're brainwashed by the
school system and the education and the
universities and the banks they're then
programmed that they think i'm gonna now
pay down that mortgage quickly that's
not what rich people do so if you want
to be trained as well if you want to
receive some training on how to find
these types of deals i'm going to be
also running
i think we're going to be heading down
to mexico soon come on baby i'm also
going to be running
a i want to run a training day and this
training day by the way i'm going to run
for free so there's no investment at all
needed and this is going to be me not
only am i going to be potentially
funding people's deals but i'm also
going to be training you how to find
deals so if you want to receive some
training i'm going to leave a link in
the description now of course there's
limited spaces so if you want to join me
on this just click the link get booked
on soon i'm going to be running some
training across the uk at the property
millionaire intensive showing you how
millionaires invest but also bringing
you in on the action so that you can
invest that way too so i'm super excited
i'm really excited to get to know you
it's been a great birthday so far we're
going to be uh heading up soon for a
swim a pool on the um a pool on the uh
my wife amanda's getting ready you can't
you're okay
are you going to be there you're going
to be the property millionaire intensive
yeah oh yeah she's going to be there so
if you want to come down
click the link below
do this quickly because i don't want
people to be disappointed because these
things always sell out and if you like
the idea of
me investing in you and in your deals
let me know in the comments below and um
i'll see you guys real soon god bless
peace out